حضر المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
اوليجا نيكولينكو حضر طهران من طبيعته
دعمها لموسكو واضافها في بيان ان على
طهران تدرك ان عواقب التواصل في جرائم
العدوان الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا سوف تفوق
بكثير فوائده دعم روسيا حسب تعبيره وقال
المتحدث الاوكرانيين ان وزير الخارجيه
الايراني اعترف علنا بان بلده كانت تزود
روسيا بمسيرات قتاليه قبل اشهر من غزوها
لاوكرانيا واضفنا الخارجيه وبالتنسيق مع
الجهات الاوكرانيه المعنيه ستواصل اتخاذ
اقصى الاجراءات الصارمه لمنع روسيا من
استخدام الاسلحه الايرانيه لما سماه قتل
الاوكرانيين وتدمير المنشات الاوكرانيات
الحيويه
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله هيام قال لنا بلاده سلمت روسيا عددا
محدودا من الطائرات المسيره قبل اشهر من
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا واضاف الوزير ان
طهران اذا تاكدت من ان روسيا استخدمت
البثيرات الايرانيه في حرب اوكرانيا
وسيكون لديها رده فعل تجاه هذه المساله
مبنيه على المصالح المشتركه اؤكد ان دول
غربيه تدعي بان ايران سلمت روسيا صواريخها
وطائرات مسيره لمساعدتها في الحرب الجزئيه
المتعلقه بالصواريخ لا اساس لها والجزئيه
المتعلقه بالمسيرات صحيحه فقد سلمنا عددا
محدودا الى روسيا قبل اشهر من حرب
اوكرانيا واتفقنا مع وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ان يسلمون اي مستندات تثبت بان
موسكو استخدمت هذه المسيرات في حرب
اوكرانيا واذا تم تسليمنا هذه المستندات
وتاكدنا بان روسيا استخدمت مسيراتنا سيكون
لدينا رده فعل تجاهها هذه المساله